[Music]
you
hey everybody we got some new Punisher
that just dropped and it is like the
return of Marvel WTF moments I know it
like I do a lot of videos that are WTF
moments for episodes but I feel like
Punisher is the one that actually
delivers that kind of stuff because I
think people were surprised by how tame
defenders ended up being but here's the
really cool thing this is basically a
character teaser so we know about what's
going on with jigsaw we know about
Rollins the other big villain of this
series and we know all the episode
titles and they're just laced with
Easter eggs but really like the big
thing here too is at the end they teased
the release date obviously they have
this big decoded theme going on with
classified data so the punisher is gonna
be using Karen page to try and dig up a
lot of classified data from back in
Afghanistan they say Kandahar there's a
big iron man Easter egg in there too so
there's just a whole bunch of stuff
going on let's start with the characters
first then I'll talk about the episode
titles in the release date but like I
said because he's a Marine it's probably
going to be November 10th I believe
that's the Friday whichever Friday that
is in November because it's the birthday
of the Marine Corps on that day and then
the next day after that is Veterans Day
so they have like a rare opportunity to
do something really cool with the series
that's just very appropriately tied I
don't know if they planned this out when
they originally envisioned the Punisher
series but they're like okay we're gonna
film it and we're gonna release it on
Veterans Day because Punisher is a
veteran in his series is all about the
demons of war and what comes home after
but the first big character is obviously
jigsaw you know him from at least some
version of The Punisher either the
comics or the former movies that he's
been in this version of the character
was part of Punishers unit in
Afghanistan so all the crazy [ __ ] that
happened to Frank over there you've seen
snippets of it in the trailer him going
up against Rollins things getting really
crazy jigsaw went through that too but
it sounds like you know what'll happen
is is they all come home and they all
deal with the trauma in their own ways
he takes a darker path Punisher becomes
more of an antihero so the series is
actually describing jigsaw as his former
best friend so we'll see how that
relationship deteriorates and all the
crazy [ __ ] that throws them into each
other's path so I wouldn't be surprised
if jigsaw now in present day is working
for the mob just like he is in the
comics but it's just that they're or
story is a little bit different just to
make a little more personal which i
think is totally fine you get Karen page
obviously know what her role is she's
basically the mouthpiece of the Punisher
to try to give a voice to all this crazy
stuff that's going on in helping dig up
classified data for him and then you
have Rollins who's a big villain from
The Punisher comics but in present day
he's become part of the CIA
so he's like the wolf in sheep's
clothing like the psycho back during
Afghanistan who's just put on a
different suit and become a psycho for a
different government agency so he's
really like the kingpin of the Punisher
series although not to forget the actual
kingpin his connection to Punisher is
really through organized crime and
there's a big element of that during the
Punisher series but I don't know if
we'll actually see kingpin during this
but they did say the next time we meet
one of us walks away and keep him was
like I'm counting on it
so I already posted that video about
defenders phase two and how I think that
the kingpin will be like the new big
boss the new Thanos of the defender
series of fully actualized kingpin right
now he's still stuck in prison
eventually he's gonna get out and just
stop all over the heroes Matt Murdock
first so I think the first time we see
kingpin in the Netflix Universe again
it'll be during daredevil season 3
because they're doing the born-again Ark
you screw with me now just a little bit
so for now Punisher is sort of off on an
island by his own but Karen page is the
big crossover she's like the Claire
temple of the Punisher series this
character is an original creation of the
show she's a homeland security agent
named ina Madani she just after Frank
but she's not necessarily an antagonist
but she's after Frank so it sounds like
there'll be some sort of crossover by
the end of the series where she might
help deal with the Rawlins problem
because he's in the CIA so it implies
that he's relatively untouchable but
then you might have recognized this as
micro so micro in this series is a
former NSA agent that just helps Frank
dig through all this mountain of
classified data so he's right out of the
comics the best I can say is if you're
not a big Punisher comic book reader
he's like the NED leads spider-man
homecoming man in the chair but I love
the way they weave in all these
classified documents - this promo
now they released a slightly fuzzy
version to this so you can't read all
the text but it's just meant to imply
all the data that he's gonna be digging
through and all the crazy [ __ ] that they
did back in Afghanistan so it sounds
like there's some big conspiracy some
next-level evil [ __ ] that they did over
there that Rollins is still engaged in
that Punisher is trying to hold him
accountable for so before this turns
into like a 20 minute video let's just
do the episode titles there's 13
episodes total like the other Netflix
series which I think is gonna be awesome
a lot of these have Easter eggs Laden
into them that you might recognize but
starting with episode 1 3 a.m. - Dead
Men Kandahar which I'll say is an easter
egg basically for the Ironman series
because that is where the ten rings
operates from so I'm not expecting to
see Mandarin or anything like that but I
just love the connection to the MCU so
Kandahar is just a really bad place in
Afghanistan inside the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in episode 4 is resupply gunner
the Judas goat which a lot of you might
recognize as a reference to the goat or
the animal that leads the other animals
to slaughter so that's why it's called
the Judas Co because it's betraying its
fellow animals so obviously in the
context of this it's a military term
someone leading their squad mates to
slaughter episode 7 is crosshairs cold
ille front towards enemy which is
actually what it reads on claymore mines
so these are all just obviously military
references then virtue of the vicious
which is actually an Oscar Wilde quote
and it actually reads patriotism is the
virtue of the vicious then episode 11 is
danger-close than home and then memento
mori is the finale title so if you don't
read Latin then that basically means
remember you have to die which is just
an awesome reference to Punisher
thinking about himself like he just he
knows that this is a mission that's not
going to end well for him but it's also
to the villains of the series like
bronze remember you have to die remember
I'm coming for you if you were at Comic
Con you saw a different version of the
teaser where he's dismantling a bunch of
drug organizations so the series is
generally pulling from Punisher max
Punisher War Journal all these different
eras there's no specific comic book run
that they're adapting and like I said
there's a few changes that the jigsaw
character he's part of his squad now
they go from being best friends to being
bitter enemies and if you look at
benbarnes here obviously there are no
scars on his face so I'm wondering if
his fight with the Punisher in season 1
gives him most of those scars going into
season 2 but we'll just have to play it
by ear and who knows if he'll pop up
during daredevil season 3 we might see a
little bit of crossover in daredevil
stunt double is actually listed on the
cast list for punisher season 1 so that
doesn't confirm daredevil is gonna pop
up because he could be playing somebody
else but it's always possible so let me
know what you guys think about this do
you think that Punisher is gonna wind up
being the best Marvel Netflix series or
where do you think that it's gonna rank
on the list because daredevil is still
my favorite character but I feel like
Punisher just from the sound of it
everything they've been showing us looks
like it could be the new favorite so I
have some new Marvel and DC to post this
weekend I'll try to get that out as fast
as possible but while you wait for
everything click here to learn all about
Nightwing on the Titans TV show they
just announced who it's gonna be and
what's going on with that and you can
click here for brand new Game of Thrones
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight